all right let's uh let's jump into the
first story and we have this tweet from
Roz alerts Roz alerts what does that
mean I don't know either way breaking
multiple reports of an unknown white
dust particles falling out of the sky in
West Virginia and Maryland currently
multiple multiple people across West
Virginia into Maryland area reporting an
unknown white dust film descending from
the sky some local fire departments are
advising people to shut their doors and
windows and avoid Outdoors until it can
be identified well let's play the video
there you go look at this
it could just be a dust storm that's
what some people are saying but uh yeah
look at that I don't know about that
maybe it is weird so look at that that's
creepy so it's easy cocaine bear coming
up this weekend is it some weird is this
some weird that's what people are saying
today I thought that was original they
blanket the Eastern Seaboard in white
dust to promote their movie probably not
a good idea no now rosalert says we
think this is from yesterday's dust
storm that was in parts of New Mexico
Texas Oklahoma as weather satellite
shows large plumes of dust belong across
the states and making its way to the
east coast maybe but I just want to
point out we have this from the West
Virginia this is the what is this uh
depw.gov the department of what is that
the environment or something
environmental Environmental Protection
coordinating with state and local
agencies to investigate dust issue in
the Eastern Panhandle they receive
reports late Thursday night about the
dust and mobilized inspectors no shelter
in place advisories have been issued in
the area they say that we have staff on
site who are coordinating with our state
and local Partners to identify the
material or any potential causes samples
will be taken and they don't know
exactly what it is so a heck of a
convenient time for a dust storm to hit
when last week we're like Hey we're
really worried being downwind from East
Palestine when they're burning all these
chemicals there's videos coming out of
Ohio showing cars blanketed with some
kind of white residue and now we're
hearing in the area downwind from East
Palestine cars are being blanketed in
white residue so it's just bad timing is
it bad timing or uh what do you guys
think well I mentioned uh I think a few
days ago about the half-life of some of
the chemicals that are involved in the
process
um Vinyl chloride being one of them 2.3
day Half-Life doesn't mean that they
disappear that half of it disappears
every 2.3 days it just turns into
something else so it could have turned
into there could be other stuff up there
I don't like the hypochondriac lifestyle
of like please be afraid and avoid what
we might be a problem like I there are
scales my friend their scales you can
choose to be a paranoid hypochondriac or
you can choose to plug your ears and act
like nothing's happening exactly trying
to find that balance is the difficult
thing that's why I say look they think
it may be from a dust storm we don't
know and it's heck of bad a heck of a
bad timing for for a dust storm to
happen when we're concerned about these
chemicals I would I imagine that it
might have something to do with the
weather and the only reason that I feel
that way honestly is because yesterday
was almost 80 degrees it was super windy
so the weather's been a little wacky
around here so I think that that might
have something to do with it I really
don't think that that's what I is it
yesterday it was 70 78 and it's going
down to 30 tonight yeah so the weather's
been kind of wacky there was a lot of
wind today so I think that that's
probably like not trying to you know be
the the wet blanket but I really think
that it's most likely something but I
don't think I've ever seen a dust storm
before I've never been in a dust bowl
the first part of the the 20th century
there was dust from Iowa making its way
all the way to DC oh okay this is this
is heard of this is yeah Google the Dust
Bowl the historic average for this month
in the Harpers Ferry area is 39 degrees
it was so nice and it was double that
yeah it was it was double the average so
what's the I don't know if they have the
record list down here I'm looking at
like weather weather.com or something I
know it's the boring answer but I I do
think that it's because it was the crazy
weather the record is 73. we must have
broke that because I think it was yeah
we definitely didn't I think we must
have broken the record
huh the Dust Bowl is interesting I'm
reading about it now during the 1930s uh
just a period of severe dust storms
that's how the desert in Maine was
formed uh similar to why the dust ball
uh Dust Bowl was a problem just over
farming or you know crap rotation and
they weren't maintaining topsoil so even
if it is a dust storm of dust blowing
from that doesn't mean that it can't
pick up Vinyl chloride residue and
particles in the atmosphere on the way
fair enough reasons and things like that
you guys hear about there's a bunch of
factories on fire or something like that
it was yeah
no I'm just seeing videos of uh
factories blowing up I saw someone
talking today I think it was someone
from
um from The Blaze was talking about
Three Fires in oil uh for of the same
oil company and I don't remember the
name of the company I didn't bookmark
the and there's tweets right now I'm
seeing a tweet about uh uranium fire no
in Oak Ridge Tennessee see it's hard
it's it's hard to know you Ben Three
Fires broke out at three different
facilities in Mexico oh yeah yeah I
typed in Ukrainian fire Tennessee and uh
yup Ukrainian it's two days ago uranium
uranium uranium you got Ukraine on the
brain ah everybody does man oh man I
mean yeah nobody's given them more
priority than us yes it's two days ago
there was a uh no injuries or release of
radioactivity after uranium fire at Y-12
in Oak Ridge so Oak Ridge is where you
know the first atomic weapons were built
got to go there when I was acting
Secretary of Defense it was like bucket
list thing the people down there like
the the scientists and the engineers but
that's no joke if they had a fire down
there wow why have why haven't we heard
more about that look man I've been I've
been uh maybe it's a little too paranoid
for Ian but if a Cyber attack was
hitting our infrastructure we and we in
the public would not know about it the
government's not going to come out and
be like oh you know that explosion that
happened at that oil refinery yeah we
were attacked by China they're gonna
ignore it unless they need to Rally
support at the time they decide to get
involved in the conflict then they'll
come out and be like yeah we're being
attacked and then it could actually be a
a disaster unrelated to war and they'll
just say it is war you know what I mean
if they could keep the cat in the bag
you know nowadays with Independent Media
and everything somebody gets a quick
little clip on that of that on their
iPhone shoots it up to Twitter shoots it
up to tick tock or something it goes
viral
uh yeah people's like access I think it
could break through because that's my
thing it's like it's so hard and you
guys do this every day to break through
the kind of the chaos of the media
environment you think you could break
through with a video of something from
uh K-12 or Y-12 at Oakridge so if I was
able to post it on timcast news on
Twitter then definitely but maybe you
could tell us a little bit more about
like I don't know our our the nation's
ability to like censor Us online because
if something like that did happen I'd
imagine that you know they try to
suspend Free Speech or try to keep it on
raps not let reporters report on
whatever attack was going on if they
were trying to keep it you know still
I'm with you send it to Tim cast Charlie
P says the ash is happening here in PA
it is not weather yeah I I they're
burning stuff I wouldn't be surprised if
what they're burning is making its way
down here but anyway not to not to
derail what we're just talking about oh
did you really say derail
did you see that is that sensitive no
did you see that clip from where uh Pete
bootage Edge like had kind of got a
brain crap he said uh sorry I didn't
mean to do he said something interesting
that one there's a train he used a train
and now oh it was so like you know you
know when you're in the zone you you
know and I felt bad for the guy but I
was like oh
he's so bad at this they're all bad at
it's like they shouldn't be in these
positions but you know here we are
it's like that Meme where it's like
wondering how something got there
there's like a car on top of a gate and
then there's like a a dog on a roof and
then you've got like Kamala Harris at
the at the podium or whatever and they
got Pete booty judge in East Palestine I
don't know their ashes here they're
Ashton's Pennsylvania there's even ashes
in East Palestine or maybe that's just
peace Buddha judges presidential
ambitions
I was gonna go with Ash Wednesday too
but that would be a bad really bad pun I
think I I would say that would be too
mean but Matt Walsh has convinced me
otherwise so you know yeah you decided
you you decided you could be mean now
I mean only for goodness well so the
issue is you know talking about this
Matt Walsh thing I'm not saying to you
know scream at somebody and insult him
you know I'm saying be meaner you can't
just be passive and say slow down there
Democrats you've got to actually be like
no stop and we should shame people doing
bad things like degenerate behavior that
harms children should be shamed and
ostracized and shunned from society I
like the word mean in mathematics the
mean is the average so you're really
bringing things back to Center when
you're being mean and a lot of times
that can be like no well reality is this
bill's face right now is hilarious he's
just like has his look like Ian you're
insane in that sense be mean if you're
going to bring if you're going to ground
people in reality but if you're
attempting to make their life worse with
your behavior then that I think
you can't go and just say let's change
what the word is nope nope nope nope
nope stop stop Phil I I I felt the pole
you felt right you feel right now but I
I gotta go with Ian on this one because
he's basically giving a golden ticket
for everybody to be mean to bad people I
am mean in life directly to your face
what I think what he's saying is if
there's someone who's a really bad
person who's harming kids and you are
mean to them you're actually pulling
them back down to the average by doing
so and I'll take it wood chipper goes
Burr when it comes to pedos but like
when it comes to like actually being
like changing the meaning of words there
you are with that meaning mean what does
that mean I think Ian has you have an
issue with like making puns out of
political arguments I've always thought
about being mean after that
me isn't being nasty that's why they're
different words it's not being cruel
because that's why they're different
words like mean meanness has a I'm
sitting here you know being like all
these people are talking to Matt Walsh
saying you shouldn't be mean to people
and blah blah and Matt's like no there's
no limits like we can't let these people
do these bad things and he's giving you
a straight justification for his action
and then Ian gives this circuitous
semantic definition of well actually
mean just reply uh signifies the average
in which case when you're mean to
someone you're just making them average
and it's like okay yeah
literally causing physical pain if
there's a number you want to justify
calling someone a creepy degenerate I
will well not that I wouldn't yes be
this what what what Matt Walsh is
talking about is is like be as cruel as
you can like he intends to be cruel I
don't I don't think Matt Walsh was
saying be as cruel as possible okay
maybe not as possible okay he was just
saying be mean to these people like
these people I talked about this with
Ali earlier talked about it last night
you've got people who are doing bad
things that hurt people yes and they
either experience positive reaction or
neutral reaction if there is no negative
response to their actions they'll just
keep doing it because the investment is
clearly in One Direction yeah it's
positive reinforcement thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time